So thank you for watching today's course on advanced landscape materials.
Hopefully you learned a lot with the bases that we covered,
whether it be from basic hand painting materials,
either the weight or height map based materials.
Also a little bit of optimisation on landscape materials
to make sure there is performance as it can be.
We discussed a little bit of virtual texturing
and how you might approach virtual texturing in your projects,
and also how to create holes in your landscape
so you can paint in caves or anywhere where you want to go through the landscape
as a player or a viewer.
So hopefully that gave you some good starting points and directions
to move in with your landscapes, and we'll see you in the next course.
Thank you.